de todos los crímenes que ocurren en
nuestros países algunos terminan
cobrando mayor relevancia sobre todo por
el interés social que generan el caso
del asesinato de Fernando báez Sosa es
uno de ellos y tuvo su definición
judicial este lunes cuando los ocho
acusados escucharon sus condenas en el
juicio oral cinco de ellos a cadena
perpetua y tres a quince años de prisión
así cierra este capítulo que comenzó con
el asesinato de Este joven de 19 años en
el año 2020 en enero durante unas
vacaciones de verano en la que estaba
junto con sus amigos en un balneario en
la costa atlántica Argentina en el
balneario de Villa gesell en un club
nocturno y al salir fue abordado por
este grupo con el que ya había tenido
una pequeña rencilla adentro del lugar y
fue atacado violentamente a golpes y
efectivamente murió por ese ataque este
lunes decía se conocieron estas
sentencias también se que tanto desde el
lado de la familia de Fernando báez Sosa
y sus abogados como desde el lado de la
defensa de los condenados habrá
apelaciones a las sentencias y es
posible que sean revisadas en un futuro
por la próxima instancia judicial en
Argentina